aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'interview
face cachée des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle j'interviewe anne hidalgo
la candidate du parti socialiste un
parti généralement classé à gauche qui
est aussi le parti de françois hollande
c'est la première candidature d'ali
bongo à la présidentielle
à la 72 ans aller franco espagnole elle
est engagé au parti socialiste depuis
1994 elle a ensuite été la première
adjointe du maire de paris bertrand
delanoë entre 2001 et 2014 est également
conseillère régionale d'île de france
entre 2004 et 2014 est ce donc avant de
devenir la première femme maire de paris
en 2014 où elle a été réélue par
ailleurs en 2020 alors le principe de
l'interview face cachée je vous le
rappelle anne hidalgo fait face à un
écran géant sur lequel défilent des
émaux j à plusieurs reprises pendant
l'interview elle l'appui sur le buzzer
pour s'arrêter sur un emoji un nouveau
logis dont la face cachée va révéler
différents éléments qui seront à chaque
fois le point de départ de questions de
fond sur son programme et sur sa vision
de la france alors n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à cette chaîne youtube pour ne
pas rater les interviews suivantes ceux
des candidats ainsi que les
présentations de leurs programmes et je
vous laisse du coup avec la vidéo
bonjour anne hidalgo dans le jura vaud
merci d'avoir accepté mon invitation
aujourd'hui merci c'est un plaisir on
sait qu est la première question pour ça
je vous invite à cliquer pour le buzzer
et
on va voir sur quoi ça s'arrête ça
ralentit sur une première chose c'est un
graphique un coin donc découvrir
ensemble ils se cachent derrière cette
màj c'est en l'occurrence un graphique
qui montre le score des candidats du
parti socialiste au premier tour des
quatre des trois dernières quatre
dernières pardon élection présidentielle
c'est intéressant de commencer par cette
question là avant de se plonger
évidemment dans toutes vos mesures est
votre programme pour donner un peu de
contexte à votre candidature et à votre
parti il y a dix ans on le voit donc le
parti socialiste qui était représenté
par françois hollande arrivé largement
en tête au premier tour de la
présidentielle en 2007 aussi faisait un
très bon score c'était ségolène royal
face à nicolas sarkozy
est ce qu'on voit c'est que et bien en
2017 ça a été ferrand comment est-ce que
vous expliquer la situation de votre
parti aujourd'hui pour commencer pense
que bien sûr qu' il y à la crise de 2008
la crise financière de 2008 qui fait que
à ce moment là le choix qui est fait en
europe et par beaucoup de partis qui
dirigent ou en tous les cas qui sont
dans j'irai dans la volonté de gouverner
le choix de l'austérité
le choix de l'austérité ces baisses des
dépenses publiques c'est finalement
souvenez-vous alors pour les plus jeunes
c'est difficile mais la grèce a été
vraiment je dirais l'exemple de 1,1
effondrement du pays il y avait plus de
services publics les gens n'avaient plus
de travail et plus de salaire
fuyait partait pour aller travailler
ailleurs et je pense que la façon dont
des partis de gouvernement y compris le
parti socialiste qui était pas au
gouvernement en france puisque
voilà c'était juste la narcose y
met cette crise a fait que finalement
les partis socialistes ou
sociaux-démocrates ont été comme les
autres comme la droite considérés comme
des partis qui avaient accompagné ses
mesures d'austérité ça s'est vu dans
plein de pays européens et françois
hollande gagne en 2012 d'abord parce que
il ya une envie à l'époque de battre
l'austérité c'est voilà revenu pendant
plusieurs années mais on n'est qu'à
trois ou quatre ans après on explique
quand même que ça va être fini cette
austérité que mais qu'il faut quand même
rétablir les comptes publics
et puis on se retrouve en fin 2010 du
quinquennat en 2017 avec une situation
un peu particulière quand même hein la
droite qui s'effondre pour des raisons
liées plutôt à faire fillon la gauche
qui s'effondre parce qu'on vient de
gouverner parce que ça s'est divisée par
ce que il n'y a pas eu vraiment d'unités
du camp socialiste elle emmanuel macron
kiwi et françois hollande qui n'est pas
en capacité de se représenter emmanuel
macron qui saisit finalement cette
opportunité qui apparaît un peu comme un
social démocrate ou un social libéral
c'est bon pour tout le monde a bien le
contexte était issu du gouvernement
voilà soit françois il était avec les
économies qu'il était son conseiller
avant d'être ministre et on se retrouve
dans cette situation où les françaises
et les français ont perdu confiance sont
dit peut-être qu'à autre chose là
peut-être que emmanuel macron ça va être
finalement une autre façon de faire de
la politique et de vivre de la politique
est en fait sur ces cinq dernières
années puisque moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est quand même de 2017 et 2022 ça a
été très difficile de reconstruire
quelque chose parce que la gauche est
très divisée elle a explosé en plusieurs
familles
parce que la droite a eu aussi du mal à
se reconstituer parce qu emmanuel macron
à exercer un pouvoir très solitaire très
dur très dur avec les plus fragiles avec
les classes moyennes avec les jeunes
très très dur mais qu' on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation où
finalement les françaises et les chaises
se demande c'est quoi l'avenir du point
de vue politique et est ce que les
grands partis sont encore là pour
justement apporter c'est des solutions
sur votre candidature vous avez dit
c'est dans l'émission c'est à vous il me
semble le 9 février je suis la gauche
républicaine lago gouvernement certains
que vous avez aussi employé il ya
quelques instants qu'est ce que ça veut
dire la gauche de gouvernement et elle
s'oppose à quoi notamment est ce que ça
veut dire que la gauche selon vous la
france en soliste par exemple des bases
d'une gauche de gouvernement et qu'est
ce que ça veut dire concrètement oui
absolument la faire quelques pas
gouverner selon vous c'est qu'elle ne
cherche pas à gouverner jean luc
mélenchon être président de la
république non il veut surtout tuer le
parti socialiste c'est sa grande
obsession depuis maintenant plusieurs
années il en est sûr c'est votre avis je
les cherche à accéder à l'elysée oui il
est candidat à l'élection présidentielle
mais il ne cherche pas gouverner il
cherche à prendre le leadership à gauche
puis le parti socialiste il ne cherche
pas à gouverner quand quelqu'un là nous
sommes en pleine crise une craignent à
une guerre aux portes de l'europe et il
choisit quoi de soutenir poutine vous
croyez vraiment que quelqu'un qui
chercheraient à gouverner la france
serait dans ce type de position donc
pour moi la gauche de la gauche de
gouvernement c'est une gauche qui
accepte de se confronter aux réalités
vous savez c'est pas facile parce que
bien sûr que c'est bien d'être dans la
protestation dans l'affirmation d'un
idéal d'une pureté et on sait que la vie
n'est pas exactement comme ça la vie
elle suppose qu'on fasse des compromis
et le mot compromis c'est pas un mot
sale c'est pas de la compromission un
compromis c'est nous sommes là vous et
moi en face on peut avoir des idées
différentes mais en fait on peut quand
même aussi essayer de se retrouver on
peut essayer d'avoir un chemin qui nous
rassemble et pour gouverner il faut
vouloir rassembler il faut pas vouloir
cliver ce sont des c'est un candidat
d'une gauche qui est une gauche de
protestation qui se complaît dans la
protestation parce que dans la gestion
ils ne sont pas capables de passer les
compromis et de rassembler la majorité
de la classe en ce sens là dessus en
matière de rassemblement on n'a pas
l'impression justement aujourd'hui
médias les scores qu'ils sont là que le
ps arrive à rassembler ce rassemblement
alors évoqué on le fait en fait voyez
c'est très paradoxal on arrive à le
faire à l'échelle locale dans une ville
comme paris
j'ai fait le rassemblement
avec le parti communiste avec les verts
et j'ai pu rassembler la difficulté dans
laquelle on est cette famille de gauche
et les écologistes c'est que ce
rassemblement n'a pas pu se construire
il aurait dû construire ces cinq
dernières années on aurait dû être au
rendez vous on ne l'a pas été ce qui est
vraiment dommage après moi je suis
pragmatique je suis réaliste je vois
cette situation et je pense que notre
pays a besoin de la gauche a besoin
d'une voix de gauche qui soit à la fois
puissante et capable de changer les
choses réellement vous savez quand on
est candidat à l'élection présidentielle
d'abord on sait qu'il va y avoir des
sujets internationaux je les ai évoqué
tout à l'heure et qui vaut mieux savoir
où sont ses alliés pour moi mes alliés
ça restera quand même plutôt l'europe et
enfin plutôt ça restera résolument
l'europe l'allemagne les états unis
plutôt que la russie ou la chine et
c'est aussi changer la vie des gens
concrètement c'est mettre en place des
budgets politiques concrètes sur
l'éducation sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
tous ces sujets encore les français du
coup avec la question suivante et pour
ça je vous invite à proposer reposer et
je crois que pour chacune des questions
et elle ralentit et s'arrête sur un
autre image vous êtes tombé sur un
imagine une sorte de devinettes vous
allez le voir derrière très concrètement
ça va s'afficher à l'écran il ya quatre
éléments qui sont présents ici dans
l'ain vous voyez où il ya un point
d'être un point d'interrogation à la
place selon vous qu'est-ce qui pourrait
être 7,4 ce quatrième élément ça un lien
avec votre programme ce que vous arrivez
à deviner
si vous voulez un indice c'est le vote à
16 ans alors ça pourrait être le vote à
saison mais ça en l'occurrence
effectivement c'est des choses qui
valent à la bière vous en tout cas on
peut mais d'alcool sur votre tweet si si
ça peut être aussi ça peut être une
mesure que vous à mesure le capital de
5000 euros pour les jeunes 18 ans alors
on a mis ça sous forme de chèques mais
ça permet d'aborder un sujet qui est
importante on m'a parlé sur la chaîne
une mesure que vous portez si l'idée de
verser 5000 euros à tous les jeunes à
leurs 18 ans première question très
rapide pourquoi déjà une telle mesure
d'abord parce qu'il faut faire confiance
à la jeunesse parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas ce
capital de départ dans leur famille et
5000 euros ça peut leur permettre quoi
effectivement de passer le permis de
conduire pour par exemple des jeunes qui
habitent dans des territoires ruraux ou
si vous n'avez pas le permis de conduire
vous pouvez pas vous déplacer
ça peut être aussi par exemple pour des
jeunes qui vont avoir rentré dans la vie
étudiante de pouvoir s'équiper en
matériel informatique ça peut être un
voyage un voyage pour aller apprendre
une langue ça peut être se regrouper
avec plein d'autres jeunes parce que
l'association pour bien qu'il n'ya pas
de l'état dans le cas où cette mesure
sur les dépenses non en fait ce que je
souhaite vraiment c'est faire confiance
aux jeunes les accompagnent et bien sûr
parce que voilà il s'agit pas de cramer
5000 euros comme ça en buvant des bières
face à frey beaucoup de bière pour cinq
millions mais mais mais a toujours une
possibilité et on n'y a pas de contrôle
n'est rien que moi je fais le vous savez
sur beaucoup de prestations sociales
dead ceux qui sont contre disent
toujours oui mais il va y avoir des abus
ça va être utilisé n'importe comment je
pense que la grande majorité des jeunes
l'utilisons de façon intelligente pour
pour leur projet et on va les
accompagner si évidemment ils ont besoin
des aides pour savoir vers quoi aller
comment utiliser cette somme on va les
accompagner une décrue mais est revenu
c'est la question du fait de verser ce
montant là à tous les jeunes il en parle
bien de tous les jeunes à leurs 18 ans
et certains estiment que ce serait plus
efficace plus intéressant d'aller lé
versée aux jeunes qui sont le plus dans
le - qui d'ailleurs avoir un montant
plus important ou autre pourquoi faire
ce choix de le verser à tout le monde
alors qu'on pourrait le verser à ceux
qui sont vraiment que les jeunes de la
classe moyenne y ait droit aussi vous
savez quand on la classe la plus aisée
par la classe la plus aisée c'est vrai
qu'elle va en bénéficier mais
franchement ça va être marginal dans le
coût de la mesure s'il fallait qu'on met
en place toute une mécanique pour
empêcher qu est ce que vous mettez dans
la classe la plus aisée en général en
général ça écarte la classe moyenne et
moi je veux pas être écartée les jeunes
de la classe moyenne donc j'ai plutôt
fait j'ai décidé de faire une mesure
générale et puis vous avez aussi des
jeunes de milieux favorisés qui sont en
rupture familiale mais il faut aussi
leur permettre de pouvoir assumer
et faire leur vie et pas forcément en
demandant à leurs parents donc mon choix
il est vraiment de faire en sorte que ça
bénéficie à tous les jeunes dont les
jeunes de la classe moyenne en général
quand on prend des mesures regarder les
bourses et et toutes ces aides la
généralisant sont écartés donc je ne
veux pas de cela et j'ai dit mesures
générales et puis à une autre mesure
pour les jeunes qui sont en précarité en
difficulté pl je n'ai fait sous
conditions de ressources qui est le
revenu minimum de jeunesse qui est je
voulais en parler en quelques mots d'un
montant de près de 100 500 euros environ
par mois et qui sera effectivement une
somme attribuée sous conditions de
ressources permettant aux jeunes de
pouvoir subvenir à leurs besoins parce
qu'on l'a vu dans cette crise sanitaire
la situation dans laquelle était
beaucoup de jeunes et une dernière
question là dessus sur ses 5000 euros il
ya une question forcément du coup
combien ça coûte de verser 5000 euros à
tous les jeunes on parle d'environ 800
mille jeunes parents à l'ordre et en
combien ça coûte ça coûte dans les 4
milliards d'euros donc c'est un coup que
j'assume que j'ai financé vous savez moi
j'ai pris le choix dans le programme que
j'ai proposé j'ai 50 milliards d'euros
de dépenses nouvelles dont celle ci et
j'ai 50 milliards d'euros de recettes
nouvelles que je vais chercher comment
je vais les chercher en rétablissement
en rétablissant l'impôt sur la fortune
climatique en mettant en place un une
taxation des hôtes succession qui va
ramener aussi des moyens supplémentaires
en passant aussi par la création de
valeur de travail la réindustrialisation
bref j'ai chiffrées mon projet mais vous
savez la politique c'est des choix quand
on me dit ouais vous rendez compte ce
que ça coûte oui on a posé la même
question emmanuel macron quand il a rayé
d'un trait de plume les 5 milliards que
rapportait l'impôt sur la fortune non
tout le monde a trouvé sa naturelle
quand c'était un cadeau à ceux qui vont
très très très très bien et là quand il
s'agit d'aider notre jeunesse ça devrait
être un problème pour moi non c'est un
choix d'où ces cinq mille euros que vous
que vous portez avec d'autres d'autres
mesures qu'on a eu l'occasion d'évoquer
à l'instant on va passer à la question
suivante toujours le même principe alors
je vous laisse à pied sur le buzzer la
roue va ralentir et elle va s'arrêter
alors cette fois ci sur un chronomètre
c'est un exercice assez simple qu'on
fait avec tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle en une minute
je poser un maximum de questions pour
mieux comprendre votre programme vous
répondez par oui ou par non l'idée est
temps d'aborder d'autres thématiques
d'autres sujets quand même pas forcément
l'occasion tout le monde à bord dès
aujourd'hui vous êtes prête faut-il
supprimer parcours sup oui faut-il
reconnaître le vote blanc oui faut-il
inscrire la con si la protection de
l'environnement dans la constitution oui
faut-il allonger le congé paternité oui
faut-il abc le droit de vote à 16 ans
oui est ce que le revenu universel c'est
une bonne idée
d'une moyens la coop 26 at-elle été
utile selon vous non ça mais chef
faut-il baisser les taxes sur l'essence
oui doit-on être capable de pouvoir
faire paris marseille en avion dont je
préfère un train
achetez-vous sur amazon non faut-il
sortir du nucléaire oui mais à
2050 2060 yannick jadot pourrait-il être
votre premier ministre oui fossiles
abaissé l'âge de départ à la retraite le
maintenir
l'allemagne est il le meilleur allié de
la france oui faut-il d'accueillir sans
condition tous les réfugiés en france
oui facile de passer à une sixième
république non faut-il interdire la
chasse à courre oui dernière question
l'euthanasie doit-elle rester interdites
en france non il faut la légaliser petit
quelque chose a dit l'aînée jadot pour
et est votre premier ministre pourquoi
parce que vous voyez des convergences
des points communs bien sûr parce que je
pense qu'on est amené à faire alliance à
gouverner ensemble comme on le fait à
l'échelle des les voilà à l'échelle
locale à l'échelle des régions à
l'échelle des municipalités donc
pourquoi pas yannick jadot qui est donc
je le rappelle le candidat des
écologistes on va passer à la question
suivante et je vous laisse
sur le buzzer
[Musique]
et il s'arrête sur une bulle les mots j
citation en fait ça va être une
déclaration qui a été prononcé par un
candidat ou une candidate à cette
élection présidentielle
on va la lyre est d'abord peut-être
essayer de deviner c'est pas forcément
évident mais qui a prononcé ces mots je
refuse la vision punitive de l'écologie
qui se révèle autorités riante social en
frappant à coups de taxes et d'amandes
je veux faire une je veux faire vivre
pardon une nouvelle forme d'écologie une
écologie de progrès de solution qui
aurait tenu ces propos selon vous c'est
un ou une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle et après on va pouvoir
évidemment discuter parler d'écologie ça
peut être valérie pécresse s'est
effectivement vallée pécresse c'était
dans le journal du dimanche le 7 août
2021 est ce qu est ce que ça vous
inspire d'abord m'a d'abord qu'elle est
pas du tout écolo qu'elle a tout fait
d'ailleurs pour freiner chaque fois
qu'elle pouvait freiner les avancées par
exemple là c'est parce que c'est ce que
les présidents de la présidente de la
région de paris donc quand par exemple
je me suis engagée résolument contre le
lobby du diesel qui était en train va y
est encore aujourd'hui mais de nous
polluer
et quand je me suis attaqué à la
pollution aux particules fines elle fait
partie de ces gens qui ont fait un
recours qui m'ont traîné devant les
tribunaux pour empêcher sa empêcher
qu'on puisse respirer donc c'est
quelqu'un qui se cache derrière soi
disant l'écologie punitive d'ailleurs
les gens qui disent le mot vision
punitif c'est en général qui sont quand
même très loin de l'écologie l'écologie
des solutions oui bien sûr on est tous
pour les quelques mentions justement que
l'écologie n'apparaisse pas comme une
punition parce que de fait certains
peuvent avoir ce sentiment là comment on
fait en sorte que ce ne soit pas oui
punition mais plutôt justement moi je
parle pas sous les munitions mais ce que
je dis c'est que l'écologie doit être
juste c'est pas juste l'écologie c'est
une écologie juste parce qu'aujourd'hui
sur qui elle pèse est essentiellement la
transition écologique elle pèse sur les
gens qui ont le moins de moyens c'est
vrai que quand vous habitez dans un
territoire rural que vous n'avez pas de
transports en commun que vous n'avez que
votre voiture et que votre voiture elle
une voiture à essence parce que vous
n'avez pas les moyens d'acheter une
voiture électrique et que pour mettre
les sens dans votre voiture ça me coûte
très très cher et encore plus cher
aujourd'hui vous vous dites pourquoi
c'est moi qui paye le coût de sa est
forcément vous vous dites est ce que
c'était tout le mouvement des gilets
jaunes avec cette idée de fin du monde
fin du mois est ce qu'on doit choisir
entre la fin du monde et la fin du mois
et donc comment la justice sociale et
juste voilà et pour moi c'est pour ça
que je me distingue aussi des verts je
fais de la transition écologique d'abord
une question de justice sociale et
qu'est ce que je propose d'accompagner
les gens dans l'achat de véhicules
qu'ils soient des véhicules plus propres
parce que propre propre ça n'existe pas
non plus pour passer par exemple sur la
rénovation des bâtiments vous savez
qu'il ya plein plein de passoires
thermiques en france de mettre en place
par exemple du mans puisque c'est une
question importante de l'isolation
thermique ça passe par quoi qu'est-ce
que vous souhaitez mettre en place alors
aujourd'hui le frein à ça c'est que les
gens doivent avancer l'argent pour faire
les travaux et qui disent bachet pas
l'argent donc ils ne font pas les
travaux donc moi ce que je propose c'est
qu'on avance l'argent que l'état avec la
caisse des dépôts qui est une grande
voilà avance l'argent et que l'état se
rembourse après au moment où la personne
va par exemple vendre son appartement où
va le léguer que la l'état se rembourse
mais surtout qu'on avance l'argent et
comment je finance sa et bien justement
par le rétablissement de l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes qui devient un impôt
sur la grande fortune climatique
justement pour que c'est une mesure qui
est porté par d'autres candidats aussi
notamment yannick jadot peut-être
peut-être différemment mais pour bien
comprendre le principe dans clueless fc
l'impôt sur la fortune que vous
souhaitez rétablir puisqu'il a été
supprimé le maquereau est grandement
changé vous souhaitez en faire ni sf
climatique oui qu'est ce que ça veut
dire très concrètement un isf climatique
et à quoi ça sert en fait c'est dans la
façon dont on l'utilisé c'est à dire je
ne met pas en place une grande usine à
gaz pour voir qui a le plus d'impact
carbone etc non je fais un impôt sur la
fortune par définition ce qu'ils
dépensent le plus ce sont quand même
ceux qui ont le bilan carbone le plus
élevé donc je fais je rétablis l'impôt
sur les grandes fortunes peut-être qu'il
existait avant c'est assez simple et ça
permet de taxer voilà c'est ces revenus
là et puis j'utilise ces sommes-là donc
de l'ordre de environ 5 milliards à
financer quoi m'a par exemple toutes ces
aides individuelles à la rénovation des
bâtiments des appartements toutes les
aides pour pouvoir acheter par exemple
des véhicules électriques toutes les
aides qui vont nous permettre de nous
passer justement de ces énergies
fossiles qui vont nous permettre de
moins polluer mais pour autant qu'ils
vont s'adresser acquis aux classes
moyennes aux catégories populaires qui
elle aujourd'hui sont en difficulté pour
aller vers vers cela donc ce sont
vraiment des aides qui permettent de
faire de la transition écologique une
transition juste on va passer à la
question suivante je vous laisse arrêté
la roue quand vous le souhaitez
la lentille ya toujours un petit
décalage est cette fois ci c'est ce jour
là d'un cadeau en l'occurrence derrière
cette màj cadeau c'est une question qui
va venir d'un autre candidat ou d'une
autre candidate à l'élection
présidentielle
je vous laisse écouter la question et
répondre directement juste après bonjour
anne hidalgo comme vous le savez la
première fois qu'on a inventé la
retraite c'était en 1910 était à 65 ans
et puis ensuite on a amélioré sa au fur
et à mesure du temps parce que la
bataille pour la diminution du temps de
travail c'est la bataille constitutive
du mouvement socialiste aujourd'hui
encore on pourrait partager le temps de
travail mieux pour travailler tous voilà
alors pourquoi vous accrochez vous à la
retraite à 62 ans avec 43 annuités à
payer ça veut dire que pour les jeunes
gens qui commencent comme c'est la
moyenne à 23 ans ça leur fait la
retraite à 66 ans est ce que ça c'est
une politique socialiste je crois pas et
je pense que vous pensez comme moi non
non je pense que c'est une politique
juste justement de mettre en place cette
retraite à 62 ans c'est ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui on rentre un peu plus tard
dans la vie active qu'il y a cinq ans la
retraite et les droits à la retraite ont
été consacrés par les socialistes par
les socialistes de gouvernement il faut
pas aller plus loin selon moussa le
certains par d'autres et à 60 ans par
exemple j'entends plutôt ceux qui
parlent de retraite à 67 ans et du côté
de chez makro à 65 ans du côté de chez
valérie pécresse et il utilise quoi
comme argument l'argument du financement
des retraites moi je considère
qu'aujourd'hui l'enjeu numéro un c'est
de permettre à des gens qui sont rentrés
tôt dans la vie active qui ont eu des
métiers pénibles de pouvoir partir même
avant 60 ans voyez donc je sais pas
exactement dans ce que raconte jean luc
mélenchon de pouvoir partir tôt en
rétablissant des critères notamment de
pénibilité qui ont été supprimées par
emmanuel conte la deuxième chose c'est
que je veux garantir des pensions des
pensions qui permettent aux gens de
vivre de leur retraite parce que ça sert
à quoi la retraite c'est pourquoi ça a
été inventé ça a été inventé pour
permettre à des gens qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie de pouvoir au moment où
ils arrêtent leur travail parce qu'ils
ont le droit parce que c'est un droit
social majeur de pouvoir bénéficier
d'abord de ne pas mourir tout de suite
d'avoir encore quelques années
d'espérance de vie et de pouvoir avoir
un niveau de revenu qui leur permettent
quand même de bien vite fait sur un jeu
il ya l'enjeu donc avec un certain
prônent par exemple à gauche un passage
à 60 ans vous l'avez dit d'autres
veulent à rallonger cette durée là est
l'une des questions qui est posé sa
question de financement puisque
aujourd'hui bien différents rapports
montrent que et bien système de
financement ne s'en sort pas qu'est ce
que vous répondez sur cette question
devient bord donc les rapports ne disent
pas du tout qui a un problème de
financement de notre système
les rapports le rapport du conseil
d'orientation des retraites est un
rapport qui dit que en gros le système
est financée d'ailleurs en tenant compte
de la population et c'est non du côté de
la droite
macron fait marrer m'emballer grèce et
emma kron ils sont là dedans il y à
l'idée que la retraite pèse comme une
dépense publique dans le poids du
du pib du produit intérieur brut et que
cette dépense publique là il faut la
réduire parce que eux sont focalisés sur
plus on réduit la dépense publique mieux
c'est pour l'économie moi je considère
que d'abord ce que disent les rapports
des experts sur le financement des
retraites c'est que il n'ya pas plus
rester dans la situation absolument pas
de mise en danger et qu' il faut bien
sûr être sérieux dans le financement du
régime des retraites il faut pas
dépenser n'importe comment sur n'importe
quoi je pense d'ailleurs que ceux qui
prônent le déplacement de l'âge de la
retraite à 67 ans ou à 65 ans font comme
s'il ignorait qu à partir de 55 ans on
met les gens au chômage parce que de 55
à 62 ans pour les seniors
moi je veux évidemment travailler sur
cette question là mais je veux surtout
garantir le droit à la retraite avant
même 60 ans pour celles et ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt et qui ont été
dans des blessés c'est à vous de poser
du coup une une question vous allez
avoir le temps de dire si vous le
souhaitez une question pour eric zemmour
est ce que vous avez une question à lui
poser je vous laisse le temps de
réfléchir quand vous l'avez vous me
dites monsieur zemmour pourquoi tant de
haine dans vos propos et dans votre
approche pourquoi tant de haine on va
passer à la question suivante et je vous
laisse arrêté tard ou quand vous le
souhaitez gassin
c'est donc un téléphone on va voir ce
qui se cache derrière ce téléphone c'est
en l'occurrence un tweet un tweet de
yannick jadot donc on a beaucoup parlé
de lui aujourd'hui décidément le
candidat des écologistes qui a twitté un
rattrapage du salaire des enseignants
est indispensable mais les responsables
syndicaux eux-mêmes ne demande pas ce
que propose anne hidalgo car ils savent
qu'il y a bien mieux à faire c'est donc
ensuite béni jadot qui fait référence à
une mesure que vous portez vous portiez
plus tôt c'était pas l'idée de doubler
le salaire des enseignants temps dans
mon livre très précisément porté encore
un doublement je vais vous expliquer
justement le jeu l'entente quand je vois
ça je me dis c'est c'est dommage quand
même qu'un candidat de gauche ne
considère pas que la priorité des
priorités au fait d'ailleurs de gauche
non écologiques la priorité des
priorités ne serait pas l'éducation de
nos enfants les lobbys % le salaire with
je trouve que c'est pas juste parce que
des enseignants en france sont payés
deux fois moins le salaire des
enseignants en france et deux fois
inférieur à celui des enseignants en
allemagne vous savez qu'un
un jeune enseignant qui rentrent en
france dans dans son métier démarre à
1700 euros il a en général un bac + 5
médias net ils devraient ils devraient
rentrer à 2300 euros et il finit sa
carrière la carrière indiciaire d'un
enseignant professeur des écoles elle se
termine à 2500 euros en fin de carrière
et vous trouvez ça normal et vous croyez
qu'on va pouvoir faire de l'école
l'alpha et l'oméga de ce qui peut nous
permettre de construire l'avenir de nos
enfants de notre pays et bien non dites
moi j'assume totalement j'assume quoi ce
que j'ai dit dans mon livre et que j'ai
repris dans mon programme j'ai dit dans
mon livre le doublement pour aller vers
ce que font l'allemagne les pays bas et
même en espagne même un espace aignan
sont mieux payés sont mieux payés qu'en
france les images le double mensonge
alors et j'ai dit dans mon livre j'ai
dit à tout le moins on va démarrer
comment on va démarrer par faire rentrer
les enseignants au niveau de salaire d
diplômé qui trouve un travail et qui à
bac +5 arrivent sur le marché du travail
à 2300 à 2500 euros voilà ce que j'ai
dit tout commence le mal est si on paye
pas bien nos enseignants et bien l'école
ce message dans l'état dans laquelle on
lire c'est justement le sujet majeur
c'est pour ça qu'on aborde ce sujet de
l'éducation parce qu'il ya la question
de la rémunération des professeurs des
enseignants sur sorte que ce soit un
métier attractif un enjeu qui est
important portée par pippa parce que sa
radio son jeu qui suit pourtant
justement il ya la question notamment
des effectifs de faire en sorte qu' on
est assez d'enseignants dans les classes
est ce que c'est un enjeu que vous
portez est la question que qui est
suggéré en tout cas sûrement parce que
tu as aussi la question des si on a des
moyens qu'on veut mettre dans
l'enseignement forcément ça implique un
coût et comment est-ce que qu'elles sont
où est ce qu'on met ses investissements
là est-ce que c'est surtout dans le
salaire des professeurs et danses des
enseignants est ce que c'est dans les
effectifs qu'on augmente est ce que
c'est les deux d'ailleurs c'est possible
aussi qu'est ce que vous portez là moi
je porte pour l'école une très très
grande ambition et des moyens nouveaux
d'abord vous savez on ne saura rien si
on ne reconnaît pas le rôle des
enseignants et je considère que tous les
enfants de france quel que soit leur
milieu d'origine quelle que soit leur
origine même géographique doivent bâtir
un effectif presque faire d'effectifs je
pense que ce qui a été fait autour du
dédoublement des classes c'est bien je
suis accroc dans les quartiers
défavorisés juste un cache sexe je pense
qu'il faut diminuer les effectifs qu'il
faut être autour de 18 classes bien sûr
autour de 18 20 élèves par classe et de
façon plus généralisée puis surtout il
faut changer aussi et accompagner les
enseignants dans les changements de
pédagogie laurent fignon bien sûr parce
que ce que dit par exemple l' ocde sur
le système français d'éducation il dit
les enseignants sont très mal payés donc
vous en sortirez jamais si vous
continuez comme ça pour avoir une école
de qualité et puis d autres choses ils
disent et puis il ya des pédagogies
aujourd'hui regardez on apprend par le
numérique on apprend par l'expérience
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus à prendre
comme on apprenait à mon époque voilà ça
doit se remuer les par le projet par le
collation la question de de l'effectif
et après on passera je ne souhaite pas
un objectif a pas d'objectif je ne fixe
pas un objectif d'effectifs ce que je
veux bien sûr on évaluera les besoins
dans les écoles les besoins en
enseignants les besoins même je parlais
tout à l'heure de la question de faire
des choix quand on gouverne et c'est
tant le sujet sur l'éducation par
exemple ou de votre côté vous partez du
principe que y'a vraiment des réductions
de dépenses à faire et en même temps de
l'argent aller chercher par endroits
c'est un exemple typique où il ya des
arbitrages potentiel à faire sur
l'arrosage la revalorisation pardon des
salaires des enseignants la question des
effectifs oui on va aborder d'autres
sujets aussi on va passer à la question
suivante je vous laisse appuyez sur le
sur le buzzer
[Musique]
et c'est en l'occurrence inde est
derrière cette màj il ya en fait un
enjeu auquel on joue ensemble mais c'est
un jeu différent des deux coups sur le
corps c'est un jeu qui est connu
notamment des jeunes c'est le tu
préfères là on va l'appeler le vous
préférez entre différentes choses et en
l'occurrence deux questions est
l'occasion de de parler de deux sujets
derrière va commencer que le premier est
ce que vous préférez
voilà je suis en train de voile à des
saignées
d'aller vers l'elysée mais je précise à
gauche ou à droite c'est la mairie c'est
génial la mairie de paris c'est un lieu
extraordinaire c'est un lieu magnifique
puissance et le pouvoir du peuple
parisien et là c'est pouvoir du peuple
français vous disait en juin 2020 au
micro de l'émission quotidien quand on
vous demandait à la présidence et 2022
vous disais surtout pas je considère
qu'il ya un endroit on peut agir
aujourd'hui qui est un endroit très
stratégique c'est celui des îles à deux
ans après qu'est ce qui a changé ce qui
a changé c'est d'abord le contexte la
pression aussi qui a été fait sur moi me
disant voilà tu dois être là pour porter
aussi nos valeurs c'est toi qui les
porte qui pour aller porter beaucoup de
gens sont venus me trouver
des mets
et des personnes des syndicalistes des
intellectuels des gens qui sont venus me
dire tu dois prendre ta part tu ne peux
pas laisser en jachère
cette place que la gauche de
gouvernement cette gauche républicaine
que tu incarnes cette gauche qui
gouverne d'ailleurs ailleurs en europe
parce que là où elle gouverne la gauche
c'est quand même cette gauche qu'on dit
social démocrate qui a intégré
l'écologie et donc vous savez quand on
est un homme ou une femme en
responsabilité ou pas d'ailleurs même
dans sa vie il ya parfois des
circonstances qui heureusement vous font
changer d'avis donc il faut être en
situation de les expliquer c'est pas on
varie un jour on pense à le lendemain on
pense à ces qu'il y a des circonstances
qui sont très graves pour notre pays on
a la guerre aux portes de l'europe on a
une situation liée aux inégalités qui
est majeure et qui est en train de de
sap est complètement tout le socle
démocratique de notre pays et on à la
crise climatique qui est là avec en 2030
l'irréversibilité donc il ya une
élection présidentielle il ya une voie
apportées dans cette épopée en ciel eh
bien je porte cette voie les villes
étaient à l'arrêt par le parti
socialiste notamment pour pour le faire
on va passer à la à la 2e au deuxième
vous préférez alors pour le compte de la
droite françois hollande je pense que tu
me reconnaîtras à gauche c'est françois
mitterrand président la république de
1981 2 milliards 1995 premier président
socialiste de la vème république
l'un comme l'autre sont dans cette
grande histoire 1 dans cette grande
histoire de cette gauche qui a permis
les grandes conquêtes les grandes
conquêtes sociales les grandes conquêtes
sociétal aussi vous me demandiez tout à
l'heure c'est quoi la gauche de
gouvernement bat voilà idéologiquement
vous sentez plus proche laisser la même
c'est la même filiation ya pas de
différence de filiation est ce que je
vous dis alors georges mai mais pour moi
c'est vrai que françois mitterrand est
celui qui le premier à pernes la porte à
la gauche de gagner et ce qu'il a fait a
permis ensuite d alternance et dans les
alternances ya la critique il ya des
critiques qui sont faites à l'action de
françois hollande mais quand même c'est
lui qui a porté d'accord sur le climat
c'est quand même lui qui a apporté les
critères de pénibilité la retraite à 60
ans bref on verse françois hollande par
exemple ce que vous voyez des
différences entre françois hollande et
vous il y en a forcément mais en termes
de vision et en terme d'idéologie qu'on
a évoqué je pense qu'on a cette même
filiation cette même filiation à cette
grande famille et avant françois
mitterrand c'est jaurès et blum et tous
ceux qui ont été là toujours avec leurs
convictions vous êtes donc dans la vie
tellement la lignée de ceux là est ce
que du coup à françois hollande vous
soutient aujourd'hui pour cette élection
il ya déjà de lui il a déjà dit donc
voila et puis je laisse à chacun le soin
de dire quand il le veut comme il le
veut est ce que j'aurai des différences
avec françois hollande évidemment
puisque d'abord je suis une femme j'ai
un programme différent qui s'inscrit
dans un temps différent où il y a eu cet
effet m et les christianites et remédier
à cet effondrement quand même de la
gauche après 2017 qu'il ne peut pas
amener et et il y à l'exemple de ce
qu'ont fait les autres partis
socialistes partout en europe qui ont
réussi à revenir au pouvoir en
retournant beaucoup plus s'intéresser
aux classes moyennes et aux catégories
populaires ce que je fais notamment dans
mon programme on va passer à la mer
question je vous invite à pied sur le
besoin une dernière fois
cette question là
c'est donc le drapeau français c'est
systématiquement la dernière question
vous allez en fait reprendre justement
une formule de françois hollande qui a
été prononcée en 2012 face à nicolas
sarkozy lors d'un débat d'entre deux
tours le fameux mois président en
l'occurrence on la remodeler le principe
est très simple vous allez avoir des
phrases à l'écran je vous invite à lire
les phrases à les compléter à chaque
fois en une totale quant à lui
comprendre votre vision de la france je
vous laisse lire la première phase et la
compléter avec celle ci mois présidente
je serai la présidente du rendez vous
des jeunes avec la culture avec les
artistes avec leur avenir
le suivant
moi présidente mon ennemi sera le
populisme toutes celles et ceux qui
veulent saper la démocratie et les
inégalités mois présidente les plus
démunis ils seront au coeur de mes
propositions
restent en avant derniers mois
présidente ma première visite officielle
sera à l'allemagne à olaf scholz suivi
d'une jour où les allemands oui suivie
d'une visite au sénégal parce que macky
sall est aussi le président de l'union
africaine est ma troisième visite sera
au kurdistan parce que je pense que les
kurdes qui se bat là-bas qui se battent
contre des gens qui revient qui se bat
pour notre sécurité ont été lâché par
tout le monde et j'ai une immense
admiration pour les kurdes et notamment
pour les femmes kurdes mois présidente
la france sera plus juste merci beaucoup
anne hidalgo d'avoir accepté encore une
fois cette heure ci cette interview
c'était intéressant et important d'avoir
votre regard sur pas mal de sujets je le
précise comme sur chacune de ses
interviews forcément on ne peut pas
aborder tous les points de son programme
et comme pour tous les candidats sept
chiots via un conte en complément d'une
autre d'une autre vidéo de décryptage
programme on se plonge dans d'autres
mesures et ces vidéos là donc je le dis
à ceux qui nous regardent sont
disponibles directement sur cette chaîne
youtube vous retrouvez les interviews et
les décryptages des programmes du coup
ne n'hésitez pas à vous abonner jamais
c'est pas encore le cas pour ne pas
louper les interviews suivante encore
merci merci à anne hidalgo et on suivra
la suite de la campagne merci beaucoup à
bientôt